when you decided not to do stand-up
anymore what was that and you said i'm
going to go be a writer yeah maybe
produce not even movies you were
thinking just write comedy
what was the first job you went and took
well i did it simultaneously because i
realized that comedians didn't want to
sell their jokes right so i said if i
will write jokes for comics i could pay
my rent right and so the first big job
well i wrote for uh george wallace oh
wow uh and george wallace said john i
got three types of jokes stupid [ __ ]
things i don't understand and what if i
was president
and i would write all these jokes for
him and and he could you make money
doing that i mean how much would he pay
you for a joke i always hear it's like
four dollars of jokers
i mean say it was 50 bucks a joke okay
or or even say was 25 bucks a joke if i
could make
a hundred dollars a week you're all set
make 200
at
comic relief and another 200 doing stand
up if i'm at 400 a week i'm paying the
rent yeah right wow and then i got a job
writing uh the grammys for shandling i
met shandling wow and i remember that's
a big break
yeah and so handling one of the best
stand-up comics right
yeah nobody better nobody better than
any of it than chandler shanley was
amazing he said he needed jokes for for
uh the grammys i was
at a comedy club in dallas texas and i
thought oh i better impress this guy so
that he can't get rid of me right so i
stayed up all night and i wrote like a
hundred jokes in one night and i sent
them to him and then i went over them
with him on the phone now none of the
jokes were really good
but gary didn't really know anything
about modern music so it was like
explaining the premises and then gary
would tell me the right punchline i see
so it was a good collaboration yes wow
and then uh hanging out with gary
shandling he's the guy who convinced you
actually to become a director right he
let you he let you direct an episode of
uh
larry sanders which is the greatest tv
show there ever was right yeah there's
nothing better and out of the blue i
never asked gary to direct just one day
he just said hey you're directing the
next episode wow did you [ __ ] your pants
when he said you're gonna you're never
directed and you're like
so so you wrote on the you wrote some of
the episodes of the larry sanders show i
was there for five seasons in all
different capacities okay so you were a
writer too yeah and so he just walks up
and says i think you could direct yeah
wow and i had avoided directing because
i was so bad at film in college yeah
that i had this fear that i would put
the film together and everyone's eye
lines would be wrong i just had this
irrational fear that it just wouldn't
make sense i have nightmares about that
yeah because when i used to do editing
in college and stuff i always have this
nightmare that i'm not going to know how
to edit i'm not going to be able to do
it it's very it's a very difficult
process so when you do that do you rely
on the help of others or do you suddenly
realize hey i'm really good at this
thing and do you start bossing people
around can you go up to gary and gary
you didn't you didn't nail that scene
here's how i would do it or something uh
well no because you know the larry
sanders show is the worst scenario to
learn how to direct on because you're
directing riptorn day one right and he's
the greatest actor ever right yes i mean
he's you know he's you know he's you
know he learned acting around you know
the greatest actors and actresses of all
time right and he doesn't want notes so
you don't do that well i read a book the
night before which is about acting that
david mamet wrote and he thinks that you
know actors just should say the lines
right he's like you know if you're
playing someone who's sad you don't have
to actually get sad you just have to
look like you're sad but like you don't
actually feel sad that's his theory
right and uh but he basically said you
know if you give anyone a very small
direction like if you go hey rip do it
like a tiny bit angrier it'll change
everything they do right like you don't
have to give them 20 thoughts you give
one teeny thought
uh but even that was terrifying yeah it
is terrifying because you don't want to
tell riptorn how to act especially if
you've never directed before when do you
ever look at that episode and go oh my
god i would have done this a completely
different way or are you reasonably
happy with it you know what gary was
right next to me the whole time so it's
actually a really good episode but
mainly
because of gary